um I don't have a religion I just I
believe in the Bible though okay what do
you believe about
Jesus I believe he's what he claimed the
Son of God do you believe that uh that
he's
created
certainly where do you get a verse that
says he was
created um
and since you asked that question I have
a question for you and and it's similar
to the question you just asked but um I
don't have a verse that um says he was
created but I do know he was sent by the
father okay so there's no verse that
says he was
created there's verses that say he's the
creator of all things you aware of
those
um I don't believe that uh I don't
believe Christians or Christianity
interpret those
scriptures
correctly that's fine we could just
quote them is that okay if we just if we
just quote
them yes can we also quote other
scriptures as well yeah we're gonna
let's focus on whether Jesus is created
or not so there's no verse that says
he's created but there's verses that
says he's the
Creator if he's the Creator then that
would mean that that he's not created
right um not necessarily true I don't I
don't believe there's verse that even
says that he's the Creator but um just
one little quick question I'm not going
anywhere with yeah just hold on because
you said not necessarily you're telling
me that you can be the Creator and still
be
created no okay so if Jesus is the
creator then he's not created right
right I'm saying there's no verse saying
he's the Creator yeah there is I'm about
to show you
look okay
here's John 1 you believe Jesus is the
word of God right correct okay here's
John chapter 1
verse3 it says all things were made
through him and without him was not
anything made that has been made
so this says that Jesus is the creator
right say that one more time no it
doesn't all things were made through him
and without him was not anything made
that was made through who through
Christ it says Christ well it says the
word here you the word is Christ so oh
okay I got you I got
you so so he's the Creator
right that's not saying he's the Creator
no okay so when it says all things were
made through him and without him was not
anything made that has been made what is
it saying about him right so what what
my my conclusion to it is I don't think
we are under we're going to based off
our own understanding no I'm not God I'm
going based off what the scripture says
bro when it says all things were made
through him were all things created
through
Jesus that's what you think is saying
I'm I'm going to read it again all
things were made through him that's
that's what it says
right sure yeah I don't have it in in my
face right now but that according to
what you're saying yes you know that
would help let me let me go ahead and
let me turn this around for you maybe
this will this will help us out here in
this endeavor of ours let's go ahead I'm
a courteous generous fell here you go
here it is I hope you're not trolling me
man the beginning no I'm not for sure
I'm not the highlighted parts so it says
all things were made through him that's
what it says
right right all right and without him
was not anything made that was made
so this means that Jesus it's through
Jesus that everything was created right
right through the
word so then this would mean that he's
the Creator
right not necessarily I mean I get what
you're say I get why you believe that
right I I I do understand why you
believe that but if we look throughout
the entire Bible it's just there
questions there you have to if you if
you stand with Jesus and stand on truth
you have to admit that this is something
that's very difficult to understand but
Christians are acting like they fully
have it and they know what it's saying
but they don't Christians is it any is
it confusing to you guys and YouTube Tik
Tok anybody can answer is it confusing
to you guys where it says that
everything was made through Jesus and
without him nothing was made that has
been made is that is that difficult guys
y'all let me
know okay I'm getting a lot of things in
the comments and wow everybody and their
mama is saying no it's pretty easy and I
understand can I a question though do
you want to ask a question based on the
verse Oh so I can't just ask a question
in regards to what we're talking about
it has to be exactly the ver I mean I
don't want us to move I don't want us to
move on if we don't settle this all
right we're not we're not we're not okay
I was just wondering
so was Jesus um formed in the womb did
he come out as a baby his human flesh he
existed before his human flesh though
this is why we're seeing this so he
exist isted as the word of God eternally
created creating everything right uh I'm
sorry um the Eternal person who created
everything
and decided to take on flesh at a point
in time and entered the womb so he
existed before he entered the womb is
the word of
God this is why he says before Abraham
was I am right I get that I understand
that but he was created into a flesh
right
he did become flesh right thanks for
coming
man man you
guys you guys are you guys are tough man
y'all are tough y are tough we got Jason
Casper in the building he says could
John 1 1 to3 be any more clear
LOL I I think it it may need a touch
Jason
I think that John 1 1:3 needs a a touch
of
clarity
somehow for some
reason it's hard to
understand when it says in the beginning
was the
word and the Word was with God and the
Word was God all things were made
through him and without him nothing was
made that has been made sorry I skipped
verse two he was in the beginning with
God all things were made through him and
without him was not anything made that
has been made was Jesus
made yeah so did Jesus make Jesus
through Jesus
[Laughter]
no good gracious
we got Simon it says Isaiah
43 66 chapters the Bible 66 books Isaiah
as the
43rd chapter coincides with the 43rd
book Gospel of John Isaiah 43 explains
God John proves Jesus Is God interesting
correlation man all right let's see see
who else we got man I'm just trying to
let's get some other some other folks up
in
here Shalom brother how you doing today
Shalom family shalom shalom I'm good so
I just wanted I wanted to come up here
and uh agree with you letting you know
and and let the world know that Jesus
Christ yahushua hamashiach is King of
kings and Lord of Lord and as you were
stating uh John 1-3 if that's not
explaining it then you just want to be
lost the next thing I wanted to point
out is you're you're a
trinitarian no no no I believe in Jesus
Christ yah shashia brother your your
background is is loud brother I can hear
like music and stuff on let me let me
step in uh acquir a place just a moment
all
right yeah I believe so I'm not a I'm
not a trinitarian I believe in Jesus
Christ that's that you got to be
baptized in Jesus Christ that's yahushua
hamashiach you got to be saved in Jesus
Christ okay so do you believe that do
you believe Jesus is the
father oh yeah I believe because uh yah
is the father yah is the son yah is the
Holy Ghost what people don't understand
is yah is omniscient omnipresent so he
can be here with us in flesh just like
that scripture that says where two or
three are gathered he could be in you he
can be in me and he could be on the
throne at the same time he created
heaven and earth so why is it impossible
for folks to believe uh to believe that
yeah but that would still be one
gathered right that would still be just
one it's not two or three that's
gathered you're saying you're saying
that the son is the father and the and
the Holy Spirit I presume is the father
as well and Jesus they're all the same
person correct correct correct so
there's there's no distinction amongst
their personhood is what you're saying
right in other words there's no it's
they're not three separate entities I
know that I I I agree I agree that
they're not separate entities and when I
say entity I mean three separate beings
um they they don't have they don't have
separate you know separate nature
they're they are the same Divine Essence
one Essence one Divine being one Divine
entity but within this one Divine entity
within this one Essence there are three
distinct persons and you disagree with
that right you don't you don't agree
that they are three distinct
persons no I don't believe I don't I
don't agree that there are three
distinct persons I I believe that yah
the father his word is also him and his
holy spirit is also him okay so when
like so for example when Jesus says that
he came um to do the will of his
father right is that is Jesus saying
that he came to do the will of himself
or is he doing the will of his
father well you you got to understand
like
Christ came to us in flesh y'all came to
us in flesh and everything is done as an
example so let me ask you a question
have you ever talked to yourself brother
yeah but I don't I don't I don't I don't
answer myself or there's not a a a a
conversation that's being had you
know not an audible conversation that
people can Witness
and there and there's and there's some
who would agree with you and some who
would disagree but let me ask you a
question is it but you didn't you didn't
answer the I'm sorry go ahead brother my
bad yeah so did Jesus come to do his
father's will or his own
will well Jesus is the Father the word
is God is that correct the word is God
but not the father see that's what I'm
saying when we say God we're talking
about the Divine Essence not the person
of the father so yes the word is God but
he's not the father he's not the person
of the father they're distinct so that's
why so in other words so so so in other
words so that will make Jesus separate
from from God is that they will make
them a distinct person from the father
they have the same na nature and Essence
as God they are distinct
persons so Jesus is not the father
although Jesus and the father share the
same Divine Essence as God so when when
when he told the disciple that you're
asking another you're asking another
question without answering the question
I
asked and and but I I thought I was
answering it
brother yeah I asked did Jesus come to
do his will or his father's
will in in essence he says he comes to
do his father's will but but Christ is
yah in flesh so the the flesh part of
Christ was man but the spirit that was
in him is god brother you said the flesh
the flesh part is Christ and the spirit
in him is the father and other words the
human part is what folks were seeing
which is the man but what was in the man
was
it Spirit of the father or something
else yeah was the was the son in the man
or is the the
son you said was the son and the man or
is the man the son yeah uh so the father
was in the son so the son is the
flesh so the sun is the the son is God
in
flesh okay
so what's indwelling the flesh that's
not the son what's indwelling the flesh
is the father
right correct and so the flesh is
identified as the sun right the the sun
is a title it's just the title brother
for the flesh right correct okay but
what's in what's in the flesh is the
spirit of the most high Y got it okay
was the son that flesh the son
created was the sun in flesh the sun
created yeah was the son who you're say
you're saying saying that the the sun
and the flesh they're basically
interchangeable the sun is the flesh
it's a title for the flesh okay correct
okay correct so was the Sun that flesh
created yes the flesh was created The
Vessel was created correct but but but
what but what was in the flesh existed
even before the beginning got you I got
you all right so my question is this
correct me correct me if I'm wrong but
is is that not scripture we was just
going through it right John The Book of
John right no that's not scripture so
let me just let me let me just show you
why this is so when it says in the
beginning was the word I'm about to show
you why this is a problem God and the
Word was God what does that mean I'm
about to show you why what you said is a
problem about to show you okay so you
have Hebrews chapter one in Hebrews 1
this is what it says it says long ago at
many times and in many ways God spoke to
our fathers by the prophet
but in these last days he spoken to us
by his son which is the flesh
right whom he appointed the heir of all
things through whom the
son he created the worlds or the
times so he says that he created the
worlds through the sun which you're
saying is the
flesh so did God did the father create
the worlds through the
flesh no no no he didn't create the word
the uh the world through the flesh not
not at all brother right because God is
a spirit so this would mean then that
the sun is not the flesh the son is a
Divine person through whom the worlds
were created it's not identical to the
flesh you get what I'm
saying you can't you can't say that the
sun is just a for the flesh it's not
because it says that the son was there
creating the worlds with the
father you get what I'm
saying so here's here's a question I
want to ask youit do do you get what I'm
saying with this no no no no no no no I
comprehend I comprehend the explanation
brother here's a question I want to ask
you so do you have something to say to
that what I just say I want you to I
want you to engage with what I'm saying
not not not bring not bring another
another question or another no no no no
no it's it's a it's an engaging brother
you know I'm listening to you but I'm
I'm trying to further understand right
so when yah says his word what does that
mean does that mean the word that he
spoke or is his word separate from him
okay so it sounds like you're asking
something else that's not engaging with
what I said so I'll answer this though
I'll answer this but I want you to
engage with what I just said regarding
the sun okay so all right so in the
context of John 1 the word is a person
he's a person he's Christ the son who
explains the father who executes the
father he makes the father known okay
that's what verse 18 says of John 1118
he is the one who makes the father known
he executes him he explains him okay so
that's who the word is that's different
from the audible words that the father
speaks which we see like for example
when Jesus is here on Earth and the
father is in heaven speaking to the son
and they having an actual conversation
and the people witnessing it they hear
the voice but they don't understand it
they think it's thunder and lightning
when really it's the father audibly
speaking words to the son so there's
diff there's a difference with the
audible words that the father speaks and
the identity of the person the son who
is the word of God the person okay
that's a difference
who explains God makes him known reveals
God right reveals the father okay so
here the reason why I brought you to
Hebrews 1 is because of your concept
that the word son or the title son the
word son is just a title it's not an
identity but a title of the
flesh so you're saying that the father
inhabited the son right the spirit of
the father inhabited
the or the flesh correct right and so
there's a problem here because if the
Sun is identical to just the flesh
that's all it is the sun is the flesh it
says here that God created the worlds
through the
sun which would mean according to your
view that God created the worlds through
the
flesh so if it says God created the the
world through the sun which it does says
that so we're going to we're going to
we're going to break it down and by the
way I appreciate that M the son this is
the book of Hebrews correct yes okay so
the book of Hebrews is
after I you know where I'm going with no
no no I I I I got a Super Chat and it's
hilarious so okay it's all right it's my
is all with love all with love I'll take
it all with love now they're talking
about a Muslim by the way but they're
not even talking about you they're
talking about a Muslim they're saying
there's all love brother yes sir now
here's a question I want to ask the book
of Hebrews the book of Hebrews is it
before or after the
gospels it's after question I'm asking
it's after okay so he was already
identified as the son but who is the son
the son is the word of God when God
speak his word is instant that is Christ
Christ is god
brother but but but this what I'm G do
because you know I I I'm I'm I'm I'mma
continue listening to your live don't
worry I'mma lock in because at the end
of the day the most important thing is
to be saved is to be saved in Jesus
Christ's name and as long as that's how
you rolling brother we locked in well
you got to acknowledge the son when
you're saying that the son is the father
there is no son or a father bro that's
that's that's the danger of what you're
saying the danger of your heresy is that
when you're saying the father is the son
you're essentially denying the Son and
the father you can't do that or you're
an antichrist I know you have a clearly
have you have good intentions it sounds
like you have a good heart you you have
a Zeal for the scriptures so look into
that and try to understand the
distinction of the father and the son
because there's truly a son and truly a
father it's not just some illusion to us
all right I'mma and and this what I'mma
do I'm because one thing word says study
to show thyself approved I'm I'm not uh
anybody that I can't be humbled to go
ahead and search the scriptures brother
so definitely I'll definitely lock in on
that note as well amen God bless you all
right now yes sir praise the Lord same
to you
peace man Manny is hilarious Jason says
John 1B the word was
with
god with
him he's with
him this shows a distinction John 1118
describes a father son
relationship between the father and the
word and yet calls them both
God you can't be a father or a son
without being a distinct
person ah
couldn't have said it better myself
Jason